hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are going to be unboxing the
brand new one plus six this is just
officially announced in London and guess
what we've got one early to check out a
really excited about this phone if you
guys know me there's a few things that I
love in life and phones and drones are
up there at the top with food and video
games sleeping let's stop talking and
let's unbox looks like the first thing
you've got is a reviewers guide wow
that's a lot of cases guys this is
really excessive phone one case two case
for case five cases Wow
eight more cases that I have t-shirts in
my closet now let's go
[Music]
the big reveal
I wonder what color it's gonna be
spoiler alert it's the mirror black this
comes in three different colors there's
the midnight black mirror black and the
silk white that silk white it should
just have my name on it all white and
has rose gold accents oh man check it
out I never want to smudge up a brand
new phone because this looks so shiny
and perfect and beautiful but let's do
it anyway really nice one of the things
that you will notice is this does have
it all glass back and all glass front
and it looks really slick and this looks
awesome
dual camera the fingerprint sensor I
love the center camera there's just
something so satisfying about pulling
off the plastic front and back with this
all new glass back and front oneplus
managed to work with a glass differently
so it feels more like ceramic but it's
not as heavier fragile and since it is
all glass you'll have much better
transmission with up to one gigabyte of
download speed which is great so I can
watch more Netflix and YouTube it's got
a Qualcomm Snapdragon 845 processor a
six point two eight inch full object
AMOLED display running oxygen OS and
with fast charge a half hour will give
it enough power for the entire day
should we see what else is in the box
before we turn it on I'm not gonna lie
this is probably one of my favorite
things about oneplus is the USB cable I
carry this USBC cable around everywhere
because it looks so cool and everyone is
always giving me compliments on it look
at this do I see that I absolutely loved
one plusses attention to detail even
inside of this USB charging brick it's
red USB cable is beautiful the box
everything it's just it's fantastic seem
another kind of good easier in here
another case I keep in the box look at
this it's so thoughtful they put little
cushions there SIM card ejector super
important paperwork has a nicely
oh how cute all right let's turn this
thing on dual SIM cards it's the way to
my heart so one of the first steps is to
set up our face data so let's try face
unlock let's add my face I cannot use my
face to unlock we go one of the things
that drives me really crazy about some
phones is they install so much excessive
software it's completely unnecessary and
I feel like it just bulks your phone
down and there's like all these apps and
stuff that you don't need so this is
very simple it's basically what you need
nothing more okay so what should i do
first I'm not even sure I love the dual
camera I'm so excited to go out and take
some photos take a picture of you guys
oh you look great
okay guys smile I'll take a selfie are
you ready okay you gotta look really
good are you smiling some of you guys
blame
[Music]
I'm very excited to try out the video on
this it does 4k 60 frames a second it
also has the new slo-mo mode so you can
shoot 480 frames a second this also has
a built-in video editor which I think is
very exciting because I feel like a lot
of the other apps that I've downloaded
before to edit video just don't quite
cut it if you like these did a pretty
good job of the notch as well there is
going to be something later on in the
software update where you can make this
entire black bar up here completely
solid right now as you can see there's
the notch cleaned up let's try on some
the cases and see what they look like on
the new phone I really just honestly
can't get over how much I love having
the centered camera everything just
looks very symmetrical so this is the
case that came with it it was a very
very simple very sleek it's kind of like
a dark grey transparent little case to
this next one is a carbon fiber this one
looks so good well I think I officially
found my favorite one I haven't even
opened up any of the other ones yet but
this carbon fiber looks really slick I'm
gonna check out the other ones whatever
I found my favorite oh man I thought
that I liked this one but I'd really
like this one too and it has a soft
little inside here's the good news my
phone could have an outfit for every day
this one's a little bit thicker because
it does come up a little bit over the
sides which I do like because it will
protect the front of your screen just a
little bit from drops
here's another black case this one is
called sandstone protective case just
when I thought that it had my favorite I
will say that this is probably my least
favorite this is the ebony wood bumper
case not really a fan of wood paneling
on anything so obviously I'm not gonna
be a fan of it on my phone actually
looks almost exactly like my hardwood
floor ok I'm pleasantly surprised as I
thought I wasn't gonna like this at all
it's definitely not a top pick but it
actually looks really really good so
this is the red silicon case I like the
logo is just kind of embossed into the
silicone every single time that I think
I don't think I'm gonna be that into
this case I am shockingly surprised this
one also looks really good I will say
that I think my final decision for what
I'm gonna go with
forward at least currently is this one
this is the black sandstone I love it
cuz the logo is settled it's a nice low
profile case well thank you guys so much
watching this unboxing I hope you guys
enjoyed this I'll put a link in the
description if you want to check out
more information about the new one plus
6ei huge thank you to the oneplus team
for sending me one early to check out
this is so incredible and I cannot wait
to get further into this and do some
photo tests and video tests but for now
I will see you guys in my next video if
you guys enjoyed this video or if you
like these types of things be sure to
hit the subscribe button and also hit
the bell so you'll be notified when I
post new videos and I will see you guys
in my next video
[Music]